大家好
我是黄子佼
欢迎来到tm 1 life超现场
今天呢这是王心凌cindy的私心线上音乐会
这个专场非常值得期待
因为在过去你可能看过我们几次的超现场
但今天呢王心凌可厉害了哈
我先来欢迎所有来自qq音乐
酷狗音乐
酷我音乐全民k歌的朋友一定要看下去
甚至赶快分享
因为今天林宝们注意了
王心凌要唱一些私心喜爱的歌曲
甚至有一些歌是全宇宙首杜公开演唱
他练了很久
你们一定要继续听下去哈
一定要锁定
并且告诉亲朋好友都加入今天的音乐会
那首先我们就来欢迎王心凌小姐登场
心灵啊
很久不见
脸都绿了哈
哦没有
他在远方准备着哈
他现在很紧张
因为真的很多歌都是首唱哦
现在我们就把现场交给今天的主角王心凌
cindy
哈喽大家好
我是cindy王心凌
欢迎大家来到我的私心音乐分享会
咖啡店坐在我后面的决定爱你
1217经做了整个下午
从交换礼物道歉
并肩走在一起
从这里聊到哪里
又聊到哪去
我不是故意注意
是不小心听见
不小心抬头看见玻璃的画面
看见男孩和女孩失去眼角泪珠
女孩在男孩肩上露出甜蜜的微笑
爱呀呀呀
就是这么简单
我
对
咖啡店坐在我后面的这对男女一人一起经过了整个下午
从交换礼物大肩并肩坐在一起
从这里聊到哪里
又聊到哪去
我不是故意注意
是不小心听见
不小心抬头看见玻璃的画面
看着男孩为你还是去眼角泪珠
你还在男孩肩上露出甜蜜的微笑
爱呀爱呀
爱呀咿呀
就是这么简单
爱不做什么
只是在咖啡厅待着
爱的小豆芽一寸一寸往下躺着
就你陪着我
我陪着你的简单爱着像牛皮糖一样绵绵绵绵绵绵绵绵
爱呀咿呀
赞赞赞真的知足
嘟嘟嘟当当当当
嗯
you need to sti st
monday to stay with st
留言才刚刚回来
怎么心又开始发呆
你没
我的最新动态
是不是你有点小期待海啊
或许我该找个机会
是他看看你的心是否同样一场大雨就会嘴角上扬
轻轻一穿拖鞋逛街
心情安慰
像是张嘴
无所谓无所谓
和你一起画面都很美
星期三
笑着流眼泪
轻轻四点能相遇
想和你周末约会
那我月才刚刚回完
怎么行
又开始发呆
我的最新动态
是不是你也有点小期待哈
爱或许我该找个机会试探
看看你的心是否多愿意
想到你就会嘴角上扬
心情一转头
谁放着心情安慰
像是吵嘴
无所谓无所谓
和你一起画面都很美
星期三笑着流眼泪
星期四天冷相依偎
想和你周末约会
心情一穿拖鞋逛街
心情安慰消失超醉
无所谓无所谓
和你一起画面都很美
星期三笑着流眼泪
星期四天能相遇
以为想和你周末一回
啦啦啦特啦啦啦啦啦
我们一起画面都很美
啦啦啦啦妈妈
想和你周末约会
i need to stand the s
just slain and slain
哈喽线上的观众朋友们
大家好
我是cindy王心凌
真的很久没有跟大家面对面碰面了
很开心
这一次呢能够透过tm 1 live超现场以线上音乐会的方式跟大家见面
前两首歌呢第一首年年年年是我收录在第八张专辑年年的
这张专辑是我自己写的一首歌
一首很轻松很欢快的歌曲
第二首歌曲想和你是在第四张专辑cindy with you里面的
想和你
也许有一些歌迷朋友会稍微在稍微认识一点
虽然他也不是真正的主打歌
但接下来这首歌呢就真的是大家第一次听到我唱了
第一次听到我的现场演出
嗯
我觉得这次也很大胆做这样子的一个选歌
但是这些歌呢虽然有好几首不是主打歌
但是都是很好听的
歌曲
是出录音室之后第一次尝到的
我希望你们会喜欢
日落前七分钟
我不懂这样一个美好的几分钟
你怎么太受
我想我已明白了
你根本不爱我
我会懂我在抖
我不懂这样一个温暖的拥抱中
你怎么也没留
如果早打算这么做
我也很快乐
我会学着笑着
日落前再爱我几分钟
月色那么从容
再多一点逗留
如果你爱过我
就别傻傻的看着我说
别离以后还会是碰哦
我不懂这样一个温暖的拥抱中
你怎么演泪流
如果早打算这么做
我也很快乐
我会学着笑着
日落前再爱我几分钟
月色那么从容
再多一点倒流
如果你爱过我
就别傻傻的看着我说
别离以后还会是朋友
日落前再爱我几分钟
月色那么从容
再多一点逗留
如果你爱过我
就别傻傻地看着我说
别离以后还会是朋友在带我姐出镜角色
那么从容
再多一点逗留
如果你爱过我
就别傻傻的看着我说
别离以后还会是不要
别离合我们的
自由
轻声说话
你孩子气的模样
一个转身
却看见让我心动的另外
幻想翅膀风带我们去远方
或许有天才有衣裳会为我们着想
爱情的剪刀舞曲
并不是说相比相爱与想念
被指间关系
天亮了
加减你欣赏了
把你抱紧
感觉自己有个属于爱情的疑问句并不是个问题
谎言会把路上的更彻底
深爱的人性
第一个完美感和先行斤斤计较的是怕失去
过往时光曾经害怕和彷徨
以为未来还在远方
原来早就在身旁
微笑洗碗
不怕幸福被掩盖
只要把手放在心上
就不会被遗忘
爱情的否定句并不是不爱你
一段感情有多少的风雨
错过多少风景
是天晴或是阴雨
期待伞下有一个你爱情的肯定句
并不是说爱你
爱得再轻
你也会有缝隙
在对方的眼底看不见一点怀疑
因为流出幸福的记忆
其实我不管爱情到底有多少种巨星
我只坚持我所坚持的真理了
我只认定的回答
认定的是你
哈
爱情的否定句
并不是不爱你
一段感情有多少的风雨
走过多少风景
是天晴或是阴雨
期待伞下有一个你爱情的肯定句
并不是说爱你
爱得再轻
你也会有缝隙
在对方的眼底看不见一点怀疑
不断流出幸福的情
谢谢
各位粉丝应该都非常感动吧
有一些歌曲是首唱
也再次强调哈
谢谢心灵今天的安排
但是为什么要做这个安排
还有在过去的17年来
然后15张作品
今天我们趁这个线上的演唱会音乐会要跟大家好好解码一下
欢迎心灵来到现场交流交流
哈喽张哥好
喝水了
没抽糖
吃的没有
刚刚在过来的路途中对
但是我发现你唱歌其实嗯这嗓子是不会累的
其实好像歌手真的会越唱越开
是这样子吗
不会越唱越疲乏吗
可能over到个程度才有可能
比如说像一场演唱会
他都要好几个小时
你到什么时候会开始会觉得累啊
不会都不会累
对我觉得当晚可能肾上腺素就觉得好像一直可以唱下去
是是我反过很多歌手都是半夜唱完了还睡不着
然后到清晨才慢慢慢慢的褪下
那个那个肾上腺素会很亢奋
然后那个状态会呃还在还在那个情绪中
就是一人生歌手了
意犹未尽
心灵的live演出呢总是那么的甜美
这么的好听
今天这个音乐会我觉得实在太妙了
因为我主持过这么多场t m e的超现场
只有你的状态是唱一些非主打好
就特别故意挑某些非主打
还有首唱的歌曲
对部分为什么要做这样子的曲目的安排啊
就是其实我接下来有一些其他的工作上的规划
首先我想要做某一点点的区别之外
然后因为大家每次看到我就是唱唱跳跳
然后我想要就是坐着好好唱歌
把一些我自己喜欢的歌
但是不可能十首歌都是主打
就是我心中的一些遗珠
但是又很好听的歌
所以掺杂在里头
所以里头有打的歌
大概就是三四首对
大概五六首是真的是比较比较没有打的
甚至大概四五首是真的是首唱完全首唱
可是我自己很私心的觉得很好听
想要让大家都听到这些歌
就是我刚刚说一张专辑大概打到345首歌就已经是极限了
因为呃可能有很多的原因
可是歌手真的会有私心
所以心灵我想问一下
过去你已经资历17年了
好三张精选12张专辑
我可是我想可能有不同阶段
比如说有你新人的时期
当你成为天后的时期
到你现在自己做老板的时期
就是这个这个过程可以让歌迷了解一下对
其实当然前期的肯定就是还是要尊重老板
这这这完全这种老板就当中历经几年哦
蛮多年就很乖
对不对
就是什么对
但是我觉得那时候还小啦
我觉得这样子也是对的
就是呃这些前辈老师们都有他们的专业
所以那个时候其实就是乖巧的听话
可是的确也是缔造出很多很好的成绩
然后渐渐当然会比较开始长大的时候
我就开始加入呃制作的部分
可是选歌也还是比较
就是还是尊重大家的意见
然后到到现在渐渐渐渐可能自己的空间越来越多
因为可能自己也越来越长大
越来越成熟
有一些自己的一些想法
所以每个阶段性真的的确是不同
是一张专辑的诞生是要经历很多阶段
就像你刚刚讲可能有收割
收完歌之后呢
可能还会再筛选
对不对
筛选之后可能还不够
又要再第二次收
有这样的案例吧
对不对
就发现说诶或者是放久了
可能又觉得不适合自己
对也是有这样的状况
所以我们也曾经说说说这首歌先收下来
然后想说下一张到下一段的时候
觉得诶好像在这个阶段又不太合适
其实收割的过程很有趣了
但是我有一个非常非常工作
非常从第一张专辑一直工作到现在的一个呃
制作部的一个主管一起工作
每一次都会他先筛选了好几百首歌
你是说你有一个伙伴是跟着你从第一张专辑到现在的
等于是它中间只有两张专辑没有参与
他等于是第一第一位把关的那第一位
他是从我是呃我还是路人的时候就认识你了
对他是第一次
就是我第一次试音的时候
就就就是他帮我试音的
然后我刚开始从最前期的很新人的时候的一些歌声的训练
也是也是先他从开始
所以我们一路就是大家感情很好
所以前面都会是先由他帮我把关把关
很多几百首歌都跑不掉
歌迷可能能想象
当我们拿到一张专辑的时候啊
这个一路这样听下来
然后顺顺畅畅的
其实背后真的有很多辛苦的工作人员
他们要做这样的筛选的动作
那么你只要听完几百首歌
头也晕了
然后要过滤给心灵
心灵再去把他挑选出来
可是在过程里面好
我们回到挑主打歌这个步骤哈
会不会真的有挑到一些啊
你真的自己心里觉得诶还好
但但是公司就觉得真的会中会中
结果后来真的中了就变你的自己判断跟市场其实有时候会有点矛盾
有可能会发生这种情形
但是大知道我不太喜欢的hook第一张传奇大家在哪里啊
在下面第一张第一张专辑的时候呃
或者是诶好像第几张专辑也有
可是唱片公司选的歌
然后可能我自己觉得啊另外一首歌更好听
所以有很多这样子的歌曲
但是今天的话就是主要是因为想让大家看到我不一样的表演的面相
走到2020
王心凌终于可以自主性的决定
所有想唱的歌
不是吗
今天的歌都是你
你想唱的是我想说
可是我还是有跟一起讨论
当然当然当然有时候会尊重
不能太那个闭门造句
孤芳自赏
要兼顾到团队的喜爱
但是却是歌迷的福气
如同我们刚刚讲很多歌
今天演唱的都是所谓非主打歌
甚至首唱的歌曲
首唱的歌曲
今天要首唱
这不是给自己找麻烦吗
因为你可能要练哪
有的歌是十几年或者是对不对
真的我真的因为这个私心音乐会的练了三次歌
辛苦你了哦
没有
但是因为真的他是好听的
我就说我想要给大家一些我不一样的表演方式
不是一出现
就是只有唱唱跳跳而已
另外一种感觉
借由这个四星呃音乐分享会
所以特别选这些
所以我自己的确也是找麻烦啦
辛苦的很多东西
可是我觉得过程其实唱的就是在练团的时候
那个过程唱的蛮过瘾
蛮开心的
仿佛也是像啊重温旧梦
回到那个时候
可能有一些做专辑的回忆都会因为这些歌而重新的在脑海里浮现
好我们来
而且我也我觉得我现在唱的比较好听
那那必须的你都不会那么纠结
你是真有一定要比当年那个专辑版的更好
更成熟的
就是好像自己在回顾了一下这首歌
然后小时候对这首歌的呃认识可能比较浅
然后现在对于歌曲的认识会更深
所以唱出来的感觉是真的很不一样
某些词意哈
因为也也许多数歌不是自己写的
但那个时候你的理解或现在是不同的
但是无论如何
今天这个安排我自己觉得非常好
以后要再来参加我们tm life的歌手
真的可以考虑这个逻辑
你开了一个很棒的一个先例
很有意思
那今天我们把所有的专辑都摆着了哈
刚刚那年年年年是在第几章
你自己记得吗
不记得
哈哈哈哈
这是第几章
第八章
对不对对
一开始今天既然专辑都摆着了哈
可不可以也顺便帮我们回忆一下那个阶段的你
或者说在录专辑的时候有没有什么最难忘的事情
像这张专辑有什么回忆吗
年年年年啊
这首歌就是我自己写的词曲自己的
这么说来
十几年你词曲或者说词或者是曲其实数量不算多不多
所以其实这一次很懒
对对我
这在练唱的过程中也有试图在反省自己
好像是可以写歌的
你为什么不多写一点啊
而且你看我写出来的歌都还蛮可爱的
我就觉得心中可能还是写出来
我也许我现在我就觉得说可以挑战看看
也许我接下来写的歌样子会不同
多多重点是要多写啦
因为你是可以写的人
自己要检讨一下
检讨一下来过太久了
那这张专辑还有什么回忆呢
哎呦我想要看一下
真的是哎呀
现在都会忘记了哦
想你想你爱太空好像很不熟
这不是你这也没有多久以前爱太空也是很好听的歌哦
对然后其中的那个呃主题曲也都也也在这张专辑里头
所以我觉得哦那时候我是拍戏
拍到中途中途偏后的时候开始专辑
那这种这种忙碌的状态剖得住吗
又要录音
又要又要就是拍戏
其实我早期之前的歌更多是这段时间的
更多是这样子
但是反而到这个阶段的时候
嗯其实已经算蛮有空间跟弹性
要好好的休息
中间要有一段休息来做两件事情
因为已经变心灵解了
有青梅姐娇哥娇哥
大家会帮你安排好合理的行程
还是要配合大家
因为主要如果累的话
声音就会差很多
这个没有办法
但是每一个这样子的天后都经历过一段身不由己
就是真的尬得很辛苦的历程
都熬过来了哈
下一个是想和你是在第几章
这个可能历史更久远的
你还记得吗
我想和你星期一穿这个
我不确定cd with you吗
第四章答对了答对了
这明明都是你的
你还在那边
好像猜不出来的样子
不是真的会搞混
因为这是只有我这样吗
我在猜
可能线上的歌迷搞不好比你还清楚这一切的意思
我觉得他们他们一定会记得
没有看清楚有什么回忆呢
就是睫毛弯弯啊啊那个太经典了对啊
那时候睫毛弯在在内地
其实也很谢谢大家喜欢这张专
到现在大家还是很爱对啊
所以说这张专辑里面的歌里面也有很多很好听的歌
像呃呃因为我从第一张专辑jj就帮我写歌
到这一章的时候也都还有收录
这题我也很想问你
我这一路看你这个12张专辑的就是啊词曲作者表
我发现林俊杰卖你很多歌诶
我跟他买都买不到
诶是吗
他写写歌给很多人
但我在应该林俊杰麦歌给单一歌手最多的音就是你
可能是因为当你那首歌他卖给我的时候
他还是个新人
所以有点像是伯乐跟千里马的一种缘分
乱说有可能就是一种情缘分
就是她的歌也很棒
但你也把它诠释得不错
成绩也很好
所以就多交流交流
对我记得我发当你是第一章的时候
收录他的歌
然后那首歌当然很大
很多人对大家很喜欢这首歌
接着隔年jj就出道
然后我隔年又发爱你
所以那个时候我们在工作上有蛮多的交流
电影很幸福啊
就是现在的结局当然不可同日而语
但是持续的他们都有很多很棒的作品
也很久没有帮我写歌了
杰杰趁机呼唤一下
好希望继续英雄吸英雄哈
再来就是日落前七分钟
这个是今天安排的唱的歌曲之一
对不对
好在哪一张
你还记得吗
比较前期的这边是后期的嗯
fly吗
ly cindy吗
哦这张有什么回忆吗
想会想到什么
看到这个封面
然后看到这些曲目
我想到李荣浩
荣浩
我帮你写一首歌
那个时候他是不是也还是是幕后工作
对她那个时候还是幕后工作
结果没想到娶了你姐妹
也不是最后面他自己也成为金曲
而且你知道他帮我写的歌是一首很可爱的欢快的歌曲
叫热爱
完全不记得
完全没有印象
诶我也没有印象
我是碰到他的时候
他说诶这我说哦对
写的完全忘记
他完全忘记了对
所以那时候就是热爱啊
日落前七分钟是我自己
在当时我就蛮喜欢古号写的一首是呃其他的歌曲
可是那时候当然在这个阶段
他们觉得那首歌并不适合当做我的形象上的一个没打拿出来
主打就是今天四星音乐会就唱给大家听的
今天就是这个重点
把一些的遗珠之憾可能在那个时期觉得怎么样怎么样
但心灵有感的歌曲拿出来唱
特别好好
这个很棒的回忆
有有荣浩的
那还有爱情剧情
爱情剧情是在心不难找吧
你真的不知道吗
你真心在给我找诶
你找答案呢
诶我对对对
这里在这里真的不知道
不是我真的是我真的是鱼脑袋的
是我连名字我都好
没事来
那这张专辑爱不爱的回忆是什么啊
那个时候呃主打我记得是变成陌生人
好好听
好写的
怎么唱
我们两个得得得陌生人拉拉写的歌
然后那支mv我整个内心很突破的
整个大露背
我不想让大家看有没有什么怎么样
是我刚刚讲崩溃这两个字
当时要求这样的突破是有崩溃的吧
前面是有崩溃
对我觉得经纪人在跟我沟通之前
也是先把大腿都掐黑青了
然后就是现在头皮来
拜托你可可以可以露背一下吗
对啊这里面我有写一首词在哪里
这样很棒的回忆哈
对这个这个拉拉也是小星星
小心你还好
来自好
会写歌
我们之间就会变成陌生人那种感情之间的那种依依不舍和眷恋
虽然嗯也许也许这个歌因为拉拉有太多作品
可是我自己心中这大概也是我前几名喜欢的非常好
当然你的诠释也很棒
因为心底的声音是比较偏甜美嘛甜蜜
所以那种那种哀伤又不会太撒狗血
你懂不懂的意思
ok就是有一点有一点嗯不会太不会太多
因为我毕竟我不是那种大炮
对对对
所以特别喜欢这个歌
好好
那么在这些歌曲分享之后
稍后请继续关注下去
因为还有很多好歌要唱
不过接下来呢要cindy来回复一下qq音乐
扑通社区
我们征集了一些粉丝的问题
我帮你挑选了六张卡片
那个问题我们来抽个三张
我帮你准备好
然后你抽完之后呢
把它念出来
好好请抽q听音乐
扑通社区的粉丝
大家想提问的这张好
第一位幸运的朋友来请念题目好
近期生活或工作上由个人规划好
刚好是岁末年终
我们又要迎接新的1年到来
2020又过得特别快
一转眼就是christmas
一转眼又要吃年夜饭了
你新的1年有什么规划吗
新的1年就是1月2号就要在台北小巨蛋要开演唱会
那这个演唱会其实去年都在内地做
去年整个下半年
然后2020当然有很多很多很多事情发生
所以大家的脚步也都放慢了
直到明年的1月2号才会到特别小清单
所以其实近期的工作规划就是接下来就是这个任务
对不对
因为照理说本来2020应该cd会在更多的城市巡回的好
结果就拖着拖着要到2021再继续巡回下去了
对呀希望
但是你伸出了一张这个买cindy啊
也挺好的
因为这个蒙古的人都可以听
对不对
有个cd出来
感觉得买cd也是内地的朋友都有
对啊对啊
他们都有这个朋友挺好的
而且也是的确也是这次这个真整个脚步拖慢疫情的关系
就后来就决定做了这张精选
可是用一个演唱会live的一种的一个的一个中间的一个氛围
把演唱会送到大家耳没错
所以有参加过我的演唱会
没有参加过我的演唱会的歌迷朋友
都可以在今年发的这张记精选里面
然后听听看王心凌的歌
有参加过的
你们可以回忆一下当时参加的情景
然后还没有参加过的
就可以先听一下
未来还有更多机会
我会告更多的地方带着我的演唱会跟大家见面的
没错这个my cindy
你在家放大声放出来
就仿佛坐在摇滚区
人人都是第一排的
感觉特别好的
来再来一题好
请选择好自己
更喜欢一个人自由自在的生活
还是可以有人陪伴的生活
你看你身边的人一个一个都结婚了
大家都找到一些归宿
进入人生不同阶段
那你到底喜欢哪一种呢
要看事情
看状况
有时候自由自在挺好的
可是啊
但本来我人本来就是群居动物
有有有时候有些状况
有一些朋友有家人在身边也很好
所以其实有时候是看事情看状况
两个都都挺喜欢的
各有各的千秋吧对吧
那突然间家里有那种蟑螂跑出来的时候
这时候巴不得有个男朋友在会吗
我敢打呢
还有徒手抓可以吗
不行不行
拿拖鞋都能就就就就就有的时候还是有人在比较好的了
是换灯泡的那种很高的
你也可以自己上去换吗
不行我就只能只能叫大你来帮忙
真假也太浮夸了吧
你换个灯泡要找人家来帮忙
灯泡你要有很高的那个楼梯
家里没有那种小小梯子
你这这起码都要那么高啊
那又怎样
没有就没有
所以就这种时候就需要另一半对吧
好好的祝福你
祝福你好不好
抽一张好
大家提问是什么
可以一直保持充满少女感的甜心教主的秘诀
这个真的很神奇耶
因为我在2003年那个时候她就是少女吗
那现在过去她还是少女
外形她的穿着
她的声线
对啊
你怎么办到的
一直保持这种很少女的状态
其实我都没有刻意保持啊
然后感觉到自己的越来越成熟
面对呃事情
面对一些问题的时候
也比较知道用什么方法去解决它
所以我你有觉得我真的很少女感吗
应该是说你的外形
你的皮肤
然后你的声线还是依然有一种很清纯的感觉
这个很不容易的
因为你就像你讲嘛
你那内在会进化
看事情的角度更成熟啊
脾气也比较少发
对不对
然后然后可是我用不同方式发很好
那就是说你比如像你的皮肤
我只能说这是天生的吧
就是天生丽质了
皮肤可能真的是真的是妈妈
谢谢妈妈
她给我的鼻子好
可是后天自己也是蛮努力
有在保养的
然后保湿啊
我觉得皮肤的状态可能多喝水呀
保对的保养啊
然后真的我觉得运动运动对
因为其实其实我们越来越大了
新陈代谢绝对没有小时候
那当然对
那你一直保持运动就会提高基础代谢率
我觉得比起年轻的时候可能喝更多的水
更在意保养跟在意运动频率
尤其运动的明白
那你有没有担心过一件事情
假设今天我们终有一天要变成四字头
50头六字头
这个时候如果再唱这些少女的歌
你会不会想象那个画面会不会有一点麻烦
到时候还是你没在管的哦
其实其实我觉得有可能某一天我就唱不了睫毛弯弯了
或者是彩虹的微笑
天空
是不是好像就不太爱你跳那个舞蹈
所以今天唱私信那个私心音乐分享会开始铺路
没错
提早布局一下
好好刚刚以上的题目希望粉丝们都满意
那我这里也收集了一些酷狗音乐的粉丝
他们也有一些话想对你说
我挑两题来问好不好
是凌乱的叶子哈
他说知道心灵刚发了这个哈精选
然后呢又要登上小巨蛋
短时间内可能没有新专辑
但是还是想好奇问一下会不会有新专辑
因为my cindy还是精选的概念嘛
对不对
有这样的计划吗
我真的都不敢讲
你知道吗
他们歌迷朋友们都追我
追得好紧
你一说他们就会很在意
你就不是倒数计时止盈
但是有辣有在做这个收割的动作
陆陆续续一直都在有
但是目前首要还是先把演唱会这2号演唱会做好
我希望了
我希望明年希望我没有承诺
明年可以有专辑
但我们现在已经开始在收割
不过就是很很前期的状态
因为大家现在更投入在大海捞针的过程还早
你就把时间拉长
5年内一定会有专辑哈
不要紧张
这样可以吧
对不对
没关系
3年内会有好乖傻傻的好
接下来下一题是来自vs
他说很久没有看到你
很想多看到你的作品
会不会参加综艺节目秀啊
甚至戏剧啊
除了大家看mv之外
大家好想看到你各种
这倒是我很久没演戏了
演戏游戏很久
因为我这几年都比较专注在歌手的身份
为什么
因为你是很多代表作的戏剧界的女1号诶
你为什么不持续的就是在这个地方再接再接再接
是小时候啦
我也不晓得
但是因为可能我觉得很认真
在歌手这个部分在做巡演啊什么的
也许有一些制作人就忘记王心凌
其实也有演员的这个身份的
在这边提醒一下大家
而且现在我越来越成熟了
可以演一些比较成熟的一些角色
那女的如果找你演妈妈
你ok吗
不会不会啊
你看哪一种妈妈就是孩子已经很大了
家母那种不行
还没有到孩子嫁娶嫁的那种
可以对
我觉得如果是那种
我怕我揣摩不了
但是现在有很多题材是孩子小小的小妈妈自己也年轻
生了孩子
这种可以体验一下
对不对
可以挑战这个真的是大家的愿望
所以今天有两大提醒
第一个林俊杰该帮他写歌了
第二个导演们记得心灵一个女演员的身份
别忘记了
现在我们要继续回到歌手王心凌
麻烦你麻烦你去准备一下
好的
待会还有很多歌要唱的好的
先去喝口水好
今天真的是所有粉丝的福气呀
就是说哎呀为什么会选这些歌啊
原来都是心灵自己的所爱
他的私心选择
大家继续的听下去
我们把现场交给歌手王心凌啊
别说
苍白
就是你
为爱
走吧
现在
未来
要来了
没有认错
不一定对
唱一段旅途只是崩溃
再没有这种机会
整个世界召开了心碎的嘉年华
会吹进的酒杯有两滴泪水倒回圈子也优雅心碎哦
哦哦你得到的自由自由
baby
oh hi
hi
丢了一些给我
baby
they turn
哦哦哦哦
现在
不在
未来也没来
没来
无心
地待
没有热也没有爱
轻轻地飞
有无上的飞
祈求一点光线再勇敢一些
再没有这种机会
整个世界敲开了孤独的嘉年华
会穿越进的酒杯
尝不出滋味
高贵君子也要压三岁
哦
哦哦哦你得到了怎样的怎样
baby我还留了一首歌
我
星星水水
华丽而荒废
该逃的时候没有逃
该好的时候就会好
谁在大哭
悲伤的欢呼
再没有这种机会
整个世界敲开了孤独的嘉年华后
摔进了酒杯
尝不出滋味
高贵圈子也优雅思索
哦
哦你得到了自由自由
比如嗨
还丢了一些给我
baby
it's time
baby it's d
take me away
nobody f
your girl in my heart
谢谢孤独的嘉年华会是收录在我的第十张专辑第十个王心灵里头啊
是我私心音乐会也很喜欢的一首歌
今天就有这个机会呢
可以把一些喜欢的歌曲介绍给大家
每一张专辑里面有很多很多好听的歌
但是没有办法
每一首都是主打
所以很开心
今天有这样的机会
可以唱那么多的歌给大家听
接下来这首歌衣橱的秘密也是我自己写的歌
比较也是比较可爱
好像我自己写的歌都会长长这个样子的
就是我内心也是住着一个小女孩
虽然现在也不小了
所以啊但说到这里也是蛮惭愧的
很久没有写歌了啊
期许一下自己接下来这段时间还可以写出不一样的歌曲
但大概也是这类的
我也不晓得
不晓得接下来的内心写出来会怎么样
让我们一起来听听这首歌
第五张专辑magic cindy的衣橱的秘密
黑风影
我曾把你装进口袋里
最有变的抽屉
你说你有多想住在哪里
再按一
我想把你变回忆处理
我只愿意和你像两个小孩子
我在一起越黑暗的地方越能珍惜世界
帮我们忘记喵喵
从此不需要看见你
因为你都在我的怀里
嗯嗯嗯
我爱你好
谁忘记了解除的咒语
我离不开想你
怕一开灯发现你早离去
把自己锁在这里
发现快乐反而更容易回忆是填不满的墙壁
当拉拉实神经是新的人变成的魔力
我住在一起
手离和自己又变不完的发型
不再需要你
我还是很爱你
把自己锁在这里
发现快乐
烦恼更容易回忆是填不满的墙壁
嘿同意
我曾把你装进口袋里
最有电脑
安听你说你有多想住在哪里
男二我想把你变回忆出你
我只愿意和你两个小孩子窝在一起
哪里来走
谁忘记了解除的咒语
我离不开的
你怀疑开灯
发现你早离去
清醒的人变成的魔力
我住在一处里
自己又编不完的发型
我不再需要你
我还是很爱你
快乐和痛悄悄来了又走
千纸蝴蝶摆动
时间就这么飞过那个轮廓
玫瑰色的脉搏坚强绽放也好
岁月从容
故事的嫣然明月光温暖着回忆
乌云传说
在看的泪长出
坚定理解了意义
呜呜呜
只为自己美丽
我的心错呀呀
被越真爱呀呀
不要为爱失去了爱
我要为自己灿烂在心中呀咿呀呼唤自在呀呀
我相信还自由安排我的没有要盛开
我相信爱自由安排我的美优雅盛开
我相信爱自由安排我都没用
要盛开
坠落星星带来光和旋律花样
整个花季开心沉睡的森林
我的心声还请回去
我是个盲区
不知要没有挑剔
那是吹变的眼睛
潮湿的夜
让冰月光温暖着回忆乌云传授心情
晒干的泪长出
坚定理解了意
哦
哦哦只为自己美丽心碎呀呀
越尘埃呀呀
你也为爱失去了爱
我要为自己灿烂
我的心却爱观自在呀呀
我相信爱自由安排我的没用
要盛开
我相信爱自由安排我的美优雅盛开
我相信爱自由安排
我的美又要盛开
曾经很寂寞
我相信而勇敢地去追寻
我看清我决定走心的美丽花
我相信爱自由安排
我的美永远盛开
相信爱自由安排
我们没有要盛开
我相信会自由安排
我从没有要盛开
相信爱自由安排你的没有要盛开
谢谢
各位朋友
今天的歌真的都好棒啊
特别强调是私心的版本
是心灵自己想唱给你们听
很多歌曲
甚至是他首唱
事实上在这段时间里面
心灵经历了歌坛的整个变化
然后时代的改变
稍后也想跟她好好聊一下
今天我们透过这样子的tm超现场领导们都能够得到最大的满足
也可以再一次认识王心凌
好
欢迎您回到我们访谈的现场
来来来请入座没
首先我要问一件事情
我刚刚看这一位好像蛮眼熟的
请问他是谁呀
小红兔
他是在哪里出现的呀
是在他其实是在第一章的精选集
哒哒哒这首歌是
然后又出现在里头
然后他其实那时候比较大
大概那么大那么大
然后我在里面就是跟他可以跟他玩互动
是然后之后呃就有那时候很多夹娃娃机
然后就有场上很多人做了这个让人家夹
对不对对
所以每次来的那些歌迷朋友来签名会
签唱会的时候就会带着这个娃娃来
我刚刚看到这个时候想
咦居然也有诶
这是谁的啊啊跟歌迷借的啊
谢谢谢谢
不知道是哪一位歌迷哦
感谢你们哈
呃当然这都是很棒的回忆
还有一个跟十十时光有一点关系
有点情怀的你其实是经历过核带卡带的年代
对不对
我们今天摆脱对不对
为什么要掩饰这件事
我们拿些等待出来后
还有经历过vcd的时代以后
这个是vcd里面是庆功版
一张cd
一张b c d
那时候还没有dvd呢
vcd可是一个时代的见证者
跨越不同时代时代一路走来
所以这次其实基金选也做卡带
在这次故意有一点好像回到那个年代的feel对
然后我的朋友是到专辑就说妈妈这个东西是什么没有看过对
然后他们就帮搭上了一下那个流行音乐史哦
这个是不是先是什么才又是什么的
他们现在连cd都不太知道
没错这一切都是很棒的回忆
尤其是cd那个拿在手上的感觉
我自己是觉得不太一样嗯
而且我觉得拆拆cd的感觉
看到里面的那一页照片里面的写真
去唱片行买一张回家
那迫不及待在车上就急得我在猜
很多领导都经历过这个年代我们共同集体的回忆了哈
但是以前要收集整套的心灵也挺麻烦的
因为也不断地改版嘛
有些庆功派就是在家里也收了很多心灵
然后你每个盒子大小都不一样
那摆起来挺麻烦的
我就抱怨我也是这样
对于一个收藏家来讲
不好意思没事
这次最新的又很厚
对对对
像植物一样
这个这么厚实在是为了想要回馈歌迷
当然买起来都是很开心
收藏起来绝对很正常
就是希望他们有更多的收藏价值
是的是的好
我们要回到刚刚唱这些歌了
呃孤独的嘉年华会非常有味道
好听也是好私心
好喜欢啊
终于有机会这样好好唱一下
终于那哪一张
孤独的家庭
这张诶诶有那么久以前吗
新电芯有那么久吗
该不会是第十个王心凌
对对对
正确baby boy的这什么回忆
或者是现在回想起来还特别想跟大家聊聊的
或者我们不知道的小故事吗
是好就是像这个时候我已经在开始参与制作
就是收割的阶段
我很喜欢这首歌
可是大家大家也都蛮喜欢的
所以本身也是力保了这首歌一票要到力宝这么严重吗
没有
因为大家会互相尊重嘛
那可是当然投票呃
对属属于这种对
但是就是少数服从多数这样子
那呃呃因为我经纪人他们也蛮喜欢的
其实收入我知道收录这首歌的时候
我就知道他绝对不会是主打
只是自己一些自己会唱得蛮开心的歌曲
很多东西很多部分还是会先以歌迷的导向作为一个呃一优先的取舍
所以这次私心就很想把这首歌再次的推荐给大家
这有这一次的约会
对今天超现场真的很棒
因为有些歌我们必须讲它很好听
但略为风格化
就像你说你拍电影拍得太艺术性
大家可能进不去
就小众一点
是的
但是呢他有味道在放在专辑里面其实有一个调和的作用
没有要多放一点
说糖多放一点
这歌放进去呢
你有一个起承转合
虽然不是主打
但是整个专辑调性会有一些变化
也让它的层次多一些
就是这首歌的功能是在这里的对吧
然后终于到2020可以唱也是不错的好
还有衣橱的秘密
衣橱的秘密我自己写的啊
在哪里在哪里
这个不会忘吧
自己写的是不会忘记第几章
在这里
这里ah jackson的7年的时候
07年的转眼也是13年前呢
对啊好可怕哇
我的天哪
那时候这一张就是那年夏天宁静的海吗
好听啊
然后原来这才是真的
你衣橱的秘密其实有打
他算是比较第四波的
后面的后面第四波的阻挡的
所以这一次选的就是第一
就年年年年
其实其他的就是比较偏后面或者是比较没有的歌
是那时候到
那你相信宁静的海的造型上就有稍微做一点点
这样子大人的感觉
然后稍微要改变一下啊
不过真的这些歌都好经典啊
有没有有没有哪一些歌是你真的是就是跟跟公司跟团队气到这样怄气
然后这样要深呼吸才能够才能够继续唱下去
或是硬要把它收录进来
有过这种阶段吗
感觉你一向eq都是情商都很高的
还是会唱
可是我很膈应的
我觉得我的歌迷朋友应该知道我有一首歌叫跷跷板
然后那时候他是三波还是第四波
然后跟同一张专辑叫木马图成绩
我一直很喜欢木马图成绩
可是唱片公司主管就很喜欢乔跷跷板这样
然后他就变主打
那因为之前一直有在讲我
我我前几天在社群就看到我的歌迷朋友吧
我在跷跷板就是就是签唱会现场表演出来
他就说我现在终于知道你为什么不喜欢这首歌
但是有这样子自己没有那么喜欢
可是还是因为她也是主打不断之一
然后很去表演的一首歌
相当于我都已经大家都我已经知道
我也就不会演了
好有一些新歌迷可能刚加入认识心灵的话
可以找出来听一下
就为什么他会可是为什么呢
为什么是不好唱
还是说呃个性跟你不符合还是什么
有很多原因
可能我私心就觉得另外一首歌我好喜欢他的关系
或者是当时编的那个舞
我觉得那些是我很喜欢的样子
可是最终那时候还小啊
还是要还是要听大人的话
那这首跷跷板会不会从现在开始封箱
我们再也听不到
我们我们走着瞧哈
看你哪天会不会突然想通了哈
不过有些歌是是这样子
因为我相信他们公司的主管们
因为他们都很有经验
他们会有自己的判断嘛
所以也不是说这歌好坏的问题
可能真的要再放一阵子再想想看
但是而且最好笑的是那个主管他是大主管
她要选这首歌
但是其他的那同事们是跟我一样选另一首歌对
但是ok啊
这是小故事
其实也是很好听
很欢快的歌曲
只是在心中我心有所属
所以当时就不晓得了
也许以后有机会有个疙瘩是小小疙瘩
所以今天都是没有疙瘩的
歌
都很搞得我现在最想回家听的就是这个时候我也觉得节目其他都白搭
就会进
我们继续看下一首沉睡的森林是在哪一章啊
新的专辑那边也是跟演唱会就跑的
巡演演唱会是透明
在这里是对他比较他在这一张专辑最后一首歌
其实他这一张专辑里面
我觉得每一首歌我都蛮喜欢的
私心的话
其实这这里头有一首叫披着狼皮的羊
羊也没有打
我也很喜欢
有机会一定要再唱给大家听一下
有机会
陈水生
你今天是第一次唱吗
第一次哇
这些歌你重新在唱的时候
因为可能距离你进录音室也有一段时间呢
你有哪一首是最难再重新抓到那个韵味的
其实沉睡声音好唱吗
好练吗
森林算是好的
他只是他只是音比较比较
因为他有一些起伏的那个对他有些音比较比较不好
主要是节奏感抓好gp抓好
其实他没有
那么我还蛮庆幸有听到彩排的
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
彩排之后又比较松嘛
所以可能有一些比较哦播出去的东西啊
哎还不错还不错还是可以的啦
挺好的好
但是呢呃好我们刚刚讲的所谓的首唱
所谓的非主打
所谓的早期卡带
我们讲b面曲啊
那么可是其实你12张专辑里面
有些专辑今天是完全一首歌都没挑出来的
对这一次唱十首歌嘛
然后所以就可惜了
离现在也比较近一点的
这张其实造型做的很多啦
然后也有很欢快的歌
b f f还有手蛮嗯
很有感情的一首慢歌
远在在眼前的你对
所以歌迷朋友应该也稍微知道呃
这张专辑的一些歌这样子对
然后这时候少女的祈祷等等那些嗯
快哥我我我其实后面的话有一些东西我都比较在打慢歌了
慢歌的一个曲线比较多
那另外一个没有诶
没有打
没有唱到的是这张这张新电芯吗
是电信
这张好像是嗯对
其实我本来也有选这张的四星歌
是叫别说歌很喜欢
但是实在是因为就是节目上之间的关系
我需要看歌词
别说重来
哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
其实小安老师写的没有歌词
我实在是没关系
我们自己会自己找时间去回味这些经典歌的
而且我自己都觉得说我现在在唱这些歌
我会更有把握
我知道那个味道完全不一样
就像刚才孤独嘉年华会也是嗯可以抓到不一样的氛围哈
而且是刚刚自己唱的还蛮过瘾
掌握度更高
这是第几张专辑
鹅心电心第九章吗
你真的都不记得你自己的丰功伟业
你还蛮妙的耶
我们这种没出唱片没办法出现
其实网上超过十张以后
我真的就记不记得了
是第七章
对你没唱的是第七章跟第11章啊
刚好是一个便利店的那个三位
哈哈哈哈好
确实这两张没唱以后一定有机会的
我相信大家都有
你会听到心灵的未来的演绎了
没错
除了跷跷板之外
好不一定了
定好了
我们来看一下在酷我音乐上面呢浏览一下大家的留言或点歌哦
诶看到大家目前这样看起来最想听到的歌是第一次爱的人
嗯
会唱吗
嗯嗯嗯嗯会吧会吧会吧哦
不要辜负他家哦
这是哪一张专辑啊
一起来的灰色
第一张第二张专辑那个艾艾琳那张专辑太经典了
其实他也这首歌也是非主打
可是很多歌迷朋友很喜欢
所以大家反而都点了这首
我觉得大家今天真是货
应该是说所有的领导都跟上我们的节奏
就点一些旧事主打的歌好
算你们有眼光
待会呢心里应该会唱给你们听的好
接下来我们要来看看全民k歌呃
我想让你猜一下
在全民k歌这个平台上
有很多人会点唱你的歌
唱歌给大明星听
还自己录视频
你有没有想过大概会是哪些歌是名列前茅
有的人有
嗯哦两个毛弯弯哦
两个字对啊
两个字啊比较近一点哦
哦大连对哎呀厉害好
我们来听听看
大家换你
我们唱歌给心聆听
林宝们加油
我们就要把现场现场交到全民k歌
各位粉丝们来请开唱
哈哈
灰色的天
你的脸我也哭过
笑过
痛过之后只剩再见
我的眼泪
3年是第一次
爱的人竟然是这种感觉
总以为爱是全部的心跳
失去爱
我们就要一点点慢慢的死掉
当我是去你那一秒突然就变老
the day you went away
闹的街
没发现我的泪被遗忘在街角
the day you went away
啊耶耶啊啊
谢谢这个是小君吗
小君唱的很好诶
而且又漂亮啊
真的唱的不错
可爱的女孩啊
漂亮女
点评一下
我觉得真的唱的还不错
有些peach都都还蛮准的
说实在的音准这件事情对你来讲应该不是任何的不是问题吧
好其实我们还是有时候会有差一点点的
我心里头都会晓得是差那一点点
但有时候是一种这种整体的一个情绪上的氛围的表现
所以那那就差那一点点
尤其像现场的时候
就是要有一种life的感觉吗
花钱买票坐在那干嘛
就是看你走音的啊
不是就是就是要看一点小状况的
那歌词就应准你可以记歌词
我就跟记者哪一张哪一张我都感受到了
我真的很金鱼脑金鱼脑
我这我这一次唱这私心音乐会这些很深新的歌曲
我真的也是把自己整得蛮真的好好
不过这也是很无奈的事实
因为毕竟已经17年
然后12张专辑要把歌记下来
老实讲挺难的
还有原声带各种的
对不对啊
我我我很佩服呃
呃有很多听说有很多前辈们是完全不需要提词机的那种
真的是我这个小脑袋瓜
真的这是整整产自己的
没关系啊
这个我们只要有你甜美的歌声
一切都过得去的好
下一位下一位我们看看是哪一位员在被催眠
真有意思
乐于作个敬业人知
苦再去对谁解释
我自己把自己下至不关他的事
快忘了怎样恋一个爱
我被虚度了的青春
也许还能活过来
心疼我的更应该明白
我当然会沉醉个痛快
让我陪她恋完这场爱
只求心花终于盛开透明
有的期待等梦完醒来再去收拾残骸
我不失去理智
情要从何开始
傻傻的骗子和骗人的傻子
可能一生一世
快忘了怎样恋一个爱
我被虚度了的青春
也许还能活过来
心疼我的更应该明白
我当然会沉醉个痛快
让我陪他恋完这场爱
只求心花终于盛开
就为了有名的期待的梦
晚醒来再去收拾残骸
谢谢子葵诶
来老师请点评子男子汉唱
你这首大名对他有一些喉音
有点沧桑
有点哭腔
桑桑桑桑
对对对
那我觉得我刚才有仔细听两个地方
因为我常常看很多人在唱
现在认真在点评上
我是被他点评比赛
我现在要鼓励大家
他这样的那个音调是对的
因为很多大概有一半的人唱错
一半人唱对
奶茶忘了怎样恋一个爱
我被虚度了的青春
可是很多人会想都会忘了怎样恋一个爱
我被去窝背窝这个字我的对
是是什么叫我背
不是我呗
不是我要我呗
其实我呗要又要爬街
比较难唱
可是比较味道好棒
我们真的没有对的
没有注意到这个细节太棒
谢谢谢谢子葵
你被夸奖唱得好啊
真是铁粉
有认真有认真听
即使是一个音都没有唱错
对大部分都会唱成另外一个是好
你可以得到心灵的爱心
一个好
恭喜中奖
好嘞
诶个人其实都很优秀了啊
今天好难选哦
我们导演主任挑了半天
最后一位来
请欣赏你的眼睛眯着笑
当你喝可乐
当你吵
我想对你好
你从从来不知道想你想你也能从美时好
当你说今天的烦恼
当你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕
都说错
好喜欢你
只不知道
虚空虚让我想得太多
也许该回到被窝
梦离合相遇
就毫不犹豫大声的说
我要说
当你的眼睛眯着笑
当你喝可乐
当你吵
我想对你好
你从从来不知道想你想你也能从美示好
当你说今天的烦恼
当你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢
不知道
哇青木很柔的男生呢
暖男在唱歌唱歌嗯
怎么样
他会让我想到那个有一点有一点点想到品品怪大哥诶
哦真的是暖男style
就很熟
温温暖的手
有些音很好听的
很有共鸣的好
这首歌本来就是给一个给大家一个很温暖的感受
但这首歌真的有一个难题
因为你不断不断地要当
就当那个当那个当叫你
而且不能每一次都一样吧
就多少有点轻重缓
因为从容到尾当很多次是不是对
所以不能当你的久了就会太太太重
你不会
所以我就会不会气气假音死音
你的突然间有要用力一点
有时候要轻一点
因为像我后面有身体
你身体的时候其实我还是会气假音
只是说你肚子再用力一点
那个气氛会不一样
所以大家下次去ktv你可以试试看
每一次当这出来的时候
你都要用不同唱法
你才跟得上
跟得上心灵姐的部分就是那种各种的轻重缓急了啊
当当有时候青年不容易的
当歌手不见肚子用力一点
它就会重一点
他会实力的是一用力就飙到别的地方
谢谢王老师
你真的好认真在跟我讲评好
我们刚刚讲的那个专辑呢
今天起直接对今天真的听心灵聊了很多
我觉得最棒的是
我们等于在这个t m里面好像回顾了一段你的歌坛历史
但似乎我们刚刚只聊到vcd
没聊到他的内容
就是honey
这张专辑有没有什么回忆呢
因为这是相对久了
这个好像123第三张
第三张第三章前面几
你这好像真的就是会印象特别深刻
哈尼嘛
那时候穿着军装的制服
延续第二张专辑的学生制服
所以那时候就在发现说萌萌很萌发
想说要怎么样延续一个制服的感觉
所以改良式的一个一个军装的样子
所以你们也拍了类似这种风格mv里头就有一个大概是这样
所以那时候这首歌的舞蹈有很多的手步动作
原来是延续一个当时的年代的风潮
对不对
这么大的流行
我觉得歌手很辛苦
就是不管是在造型或者是妆妆容妆容对不对
都要跟着那个时代有
有的时候你现在回头画
那不怪怪的
不是那么合适
可是当下是ok的
当下非常好
或是一些动作的
就当时流行什么歌手都要去继续引领流行没错
所以那时候舞蹈才会这样特别的设计
那讲到这个
你看记歌词你不太不太行
然后然后专辑的顺序也不太行
没有大概六章以前都还peach
没有问题
那既舞蹈动作你行不行呢
因为毕竟你有好多唱跳歌曲
对你你记舞蹈练舞的速度算是快的吗
还行还行
其实我记东西都挺慢的
糟糕了
是不是啊啊但是我就会我就会很愿意花时间
你小时候考试考试顺利吗
顺利背那些东西还蛮
可是我就是临时抱佛脚心哦背了
然后短跑型的考试考完就全部还给老师
也没有
还是有还是有记得一些别的a到z你可以背得起来吗
可以可以好
a开始a b c d e f g h i j k l为什么要考这卡
l l l l m n o p q u r s t u v w x y z漂亮啊
好可哈哈
事实证明请你还是可以的
是不是就记该记得是记得
其实人有的时候健忘一点也挺快乐的
没错有时候开心的事情忘得特别快
没错特别乐观
非常谢谢心灵
稍后呢好像也会安排哈尼里面的一首歌
就是往幸福出发出发出发吧
这首歌唱过吗
往幸福出发吧
也是第一次唱歌
首唱好
好好请您请就位好
待会见王幸福出发吧
稍后会为大家演唱
来自这张哈尼第三张专辑
今天是全世界全宇宙首唱
感谢各位今天的收看
tm 1 live超现场
真的是值得了
再次的感谢qq音乐
酷狗音乐
酷我音乐
全民k歌
所有的伙伴
大家的陪伴
最重要是代表心灵
谢谢所有的领导长期的支持
现在就把现场交给王心凌嗯
honey h
啊
色的天
你的脸我也哭过
笑过
痛过之后只剩再见
我的眼泪
去第一次爱的人竟然是这种感觉
总以为爱是全部的心跳
失去爱
我们就要请一天天慢慢的死掉
我失去你那一秒
心突然就变老
do you away
闹的街
没发现我的泪被遗忘在街角
the day you went away
哦耶耶
看着雨走了街
穿着去年夏天我送你的那双球鞋
银色收敛
了解你的世界
不一点也没有因此改变
总以为爱是全部的心
心跳失去爱
我们就要要一点点慢慢的死掉
当我失去你那一秒
心突然就变老
see you anyway
闹的街
没发现我的泪被遗忘在街角
the day you went away
away the day
you went away
哦耶耶
我总以为爱是全部的心跳
失去爱
我们就要一点点慢慢的死掉
当我失去你那一秒
心突然就变老
when you wa
闹的街
没发现我的泪被遗忘在街角
the day you went away
一天也许我能把自己治好
再一次想起来应该要怎么笑一次爱的人
他的坏
他的好
却像胸口刺青
是永远的记号
我的呼吸直到停止心跳
啊啊啊
刚刚这首是第二张专辑
收录在爱你这张专辑里头的歌曲
也是非主打叫地菜的人
但我知道有很多内地的歌迷朋友很喜欢这首歌
他在也非常受欢迎
所以其实每次我演出的时候
常常都不会错过这首歌
因为是一首很可以跟大家一起互动大合唱的一首歌曲
看来这首歌就真的是出了录音室之后再也没唱过的一首歌
也是第一次第一次的公开演唱
往幸福出发吧
收录在第三张专辑哈尼里头
是一首很轻快啊
听得很开心的一首歌啊
希望线上的朋友们啊听到这首歌的时候
可以跟我们一起摇摆
希望我的工作人员也可以跟着我一起摇摆
让我们听一下这首欢快的歌曲
幸福出发吧
永远那么热烈
问她失恋了
你的改变
笑的脸上还有眼泪
互相宝贝
互相当年迷惑也会疲倦
要加油一点
摸摸头
擦干了双眼
要走得更远
无法我幸福出发吧
勇敢寻找让自己能发亮的地方
爱给我们能量
转过身技术的飞翔
天上星星深情又落下
紧接着心一直说到天亮
靠着彼此的肩膀
这样的我们很棒
不是吗
聊的忘了时间
有情比爱情更不容易疲倦
很开心
有人能看见的那一面
整个一点人生很难
梦想很贵
要加油一点
未来多远
要是不快乐
为何不甘愿
出发吧
往幸福出发吧
勇敢寻找
让自己能发亮的地方
你给我们能量
转过身
继续朝向蓝天上飞翔
有对方的祝福就能倒退的地方
心情不撞
跌倒了可以撒娇
心灰
星星升起又落下
心贴着心
一直说到天亮
靠着彼此的肩膀
这样对我们很棒
不是吗
很难梦想很贵
要加油一点
但未来多远
要是不快乐
会不甘愿悔恨
不甘愿
不管多远
寻找让自己能发亮的地方
给我们能量
转过身
继续朝向蓝天上飞翔
放个祝福就能倒退的地方
希望心情都装勇敢的面对每一天
你在身旁
大家热情地支持与配合
不知道线上的你们是不是也跟我们的工作人员一样
今天谢谢大家的参与
然后啊今天的很多首歌曲
希望你们都会喜欢
有一些歌呢是第一次听到
也许之后也不真的会有机会再听到
但是这些歌我自己唱得很开心
因为我没有忘记这些歌
他们都是我们一起共同的一个美好回忆
谢谢你们
今天最后一首歌曲
当你让我们回到第一张专辑cindy in
有一天我回到从前到最原始的
我是否会觉得我不错
有一天我离你遥远
再和你相约
是否会发觉我已经说再见
你的眼睛眯着笑
当你喝可乐
当你吵
我想想对你好
你从来不知道想你想你也能成微信好
当你说今天的烦恼
当你你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢你
只不知道
如果有一天梦想都实现
你都成了永远是否还会记得今天
我有一天我们都发觉原来什么都可以
是否还会停留在这里起来
当你的眼睛眯着笑
当你和可乐
当你吵
我想对你好
你从来不知道想你
想你很久
为嗜好
当你说今天的烦恼
但你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢你
只不知道
空虚让我想得太多
该回到被窝
梦里会相遇
就毫不犹豫真的说
我要说
当你的眼睛眯着笑
当你喝可乐
当你吵
我想对你好
你从还不知道想你
想你也能成为嗜好
啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢你
只不知道
啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
谢谢大家
谢谢在线上收看的每一个你们
希望你们喜欢景点的节目
谢谢所有的工作人员
谢谢谢谢乐手老师们
辛苦了拜拜辛苦了